on target
an impressive enough feet under normal
circumstances but in this case it's
remarkable because this man is
completely blind
Durand perk who lost his sight at the
age of eleven is only the second person
in the Netherlands to be fitted with a
bionic eye the implant officially known
as the Argos to retinal prosthesis
system is made up of a miniature camera
a transmitting chip a plate with 60
electrodes implanted in the eye and a
tiny computer unit bionic eye works by
converting video captured by the glasses
into pulses of electricity that
stimulate healthy retinal cells allowing
the wearer to see colors and shapes
if you've Nibbana many things have
changed in my life for the better since
I used Argus 2 I've become more
confident and I can do more things and
visualize more things dr. Mark O'Meara
who carried out the implant procedure on
perc says he hopes the new technology
will soon benefit other visually
impaired patients at the time at the
time being at the moment we are
experiencing only with residents
pigmentosa but there are a lot of other
diseases in the eye where the
photoreceptors are damaged and where the
optic nerve seed works
so those are the diseases that can be
targeted with this type of device Burke
has already seen his life transformed by
the bionic eye but recently I was at a
concert
I enjoyed the light show I could see the
form of light and when I was close to
the stage I could visualize a band and a
guitar player that experience was so
great
you